[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette semaine je pense que j'ai envie de
célébrer parce que la nouvelle qui est
arrivé est quand même assez fantastique
on parle de Kony Walker une journaliste
anciennement de la CBC maintenant qui
est avec gimlet midi aux États-Unis qui
ont reçu un non un deux prix extrêmement
prestigieux en journaliste premièrement
le prix polyzer que je pense personne a
besoin de se faire rappeler comment
c'est gros mais vainqueur plus tard le
prix body pour justement le podcast que
le créer qui s'appelle Stallone
et c'est un podcast qui est sûr Spotify
qui parle de l'expérience d'un homme
racontant à travers sa fille sur son
expérience des pensionnats c'est
extraordinaire non seulement je pense
que le fait que prenez Walker reçoivent
deux prix en 24 heures de prix
prestigieux pour son travail de
journaliste
mais c'est de voir où ce à quel point
quand on décolonise quand on enlève
justement les murs de verre dans les
communautés
on peut permettre justement l'ouverture
des oreilles aussi une écoute c'est plus
seulement des des articles spécialisés
ce sont maintenant des nouvelles de la
même qualité à l'échelle mondiale donc
la reconnaissance de son travail parce
que quand même connu dans les
communautés pour son travail là je
dirais c'est déjà une femme
professionnelle mais que ces histoires
là commencent à être entendu écouter et
partager
vous comprendrez que non seulement on va
reconnaître la qualité du travail d'une
journaliste et il y en a pas beaucoup
des journalistes autochtones mais il y
en a énormément qui sont en train de
sortir justement parce qu'il y a de plus
en plus de demandes parce qu'il y a de
plus en plus de reconnaissance aussi et
je pense que ce qui est fantastique
aussi qu'on va commencer à voir les
journalistes autochtones comme étant
capables de parler de sujets multiples
autre que autochtone mais pour l'instant
il y a encore un besoin pour
l'information pour que ces
informations-là soit connue et soirée
pendus donc ça c'est déjà la
reconnaissance des journalistes
autochtones du milieu mais aussi
ce qu'il faut vraiment voir ce que
j'aime entendre c'est quand quelqu'un
reçoit un prix tel que le Peabody ou le
Poulidor ah ben là c'est quoi cette
nouvelle là c'est quoi c'est pas une
question c'est quoi ça les pensions
parce que vous seriez étonné combien de
personnes sont pas encore au courant de
l'historique des pensionnats et aussi ça
va ouvrir l'oreille à des personnes qui
auraient pas été touchées par des enjeux
de justice des enjeux historiques comme
les pensionnats donc je trouve qu'on
gagne à deux échelles on gagne en
gagnant de la représentation en montrant
justement à des jeunes qui voudraient
prendre le journaliste et qui voit
maintenant qu'il y a des possibilités
qu'on peut être reconnues pour son
travail et de l'autre côté et bien on
voit que la nouvelle voyage que si on
peut des histoires qui ne concerne que
les gens intéressés par les enjeux
autochtones ce sont des enjeux de
journalistes à l'échelle mondiale et
donc ils vont voyager ils vont être
entendus ce qui par le passé était très
difficile je veux dire c'est pas la
première fois qu'on parle des passionnés
des femmes assassin disparues mais à
force d'en parler ça commence à devenir
une nouvelle qui concerne les Canadiens
et même les gens à travers la planète
donc extrêmement contente vraiment fier
de voir que on commence à avoir l'écoute
parce qu'on n'a jamais arrêté de vouloir
se faire entendre d'une façon quand même
positive quand même très
juste donc on se lève
et j'espère que vous allez aller écouter
le podcast je vous rappelle c'est stolen
et surviving sainte Michaels qui se
trouve sur Spotify je vous souhaite une
belle semaine